INTRO:
By now, I’m sure you’ve all heard
about the supply shortage. It’s all over the news
and many of you have likely experienced it first
hand. It’s no secret that wait times and prices
for many everyday items have gone through the
roof. To make things worse, it looks like things
are only getting worse. Take Tesla for example.
Wait time for the model 3 are 3 to 6 months.
Wait times for the model Y are 6 to 9 months.
Wait times for the model S are 3 to 6 months. Wait
times for the model X are 9 to 12 months. And the
Cybertruck is nowhere to be found. Clearly,
Tesla has months of backlog for all of their
vehicles. Yet, their Q2 production numbers are
down nearly 50,000 in comparison to Q1. And this
is despite opening two new gigafactories within
the past couple of months. According to Elon,
these factories are currently “gigantic money
furnaces” because they simply can’t get enough
parts to reach they scale that they need to.
It’s not just Tesla that’s facing these issues
either. Even Apple is worried that supply chain
constraints will affect their top line by several
billion dollars. But, why is this still even an
issue? Our freight networks, trucking networks,
airline networks, and communication networks
are all more advanced than ever. So,
you would think that such an issue would be solved
within a matter of months. But, we’re two years
into this problem and things are only getting
worse. So, what’s up with the supply shortage?
PANDEMIC:
Starting with the most obvious reason, we have the
pandemic. While much of the world has returned to
normal life, the effects of the pandemic are still
quite evident throughout the supply chain. First
of all, China is still regularly implementing
lockdowns in even some of their biggest cities
like Shanghai. And given that a significant
portion of our everyday items are produced in
China, it’s not surprising that these lockdowns
are taking a toll on the global marketplace.
It’s not just lockdowns that we have to worry
about either. Covid has brought with it a slew
of new safety protocols from regular testing to
strict quarantine measures. And this has simply
added more friction when it comes to maximizing
production and logistics. But, even if lockdowns
and covid protocols were left behind, we would
face issues regarding labor shortages. You see,
when the pandemic hit, many companies scaled back
production to prepare for potentially weak demand.
This meant shutting down factories and laying
off a significant number of employees. This
made sense at the time but demand has recovered
faster than anyone expected. Not to mention,
in some industries, demand is higher than ever
because people have been excited to return to
normal life. The problem, however, is that it
takes time to scale up production. While you can
shutdown a factory overnight, you can’t just turn
it back on overnight. A great example is Tesla
Gigafactories. It generally takes years for these
behemoths to reach their strides, and even then,
they still have years worth of optimization left.
Also, it’s not just one or two factories that were
shutdown. Much of the supply chain as a whole
was shut down, so everyone is having to scale
back up all over again. To make things worse, it’s
been extremely difficult to find enough labor to
run these factories and logistics networks. This
was already an issue before the pandemic started,
but the pandemic just made this problem
substantially worse. You see, many of the
manufacturing employees that were furloughed
or laid off simply didn’t return. Instead they
found new jobs that were more flexible and paid
better. By now, I’m sure you’ve all heard about
the great resignation, and one of the hardest hit
industries in manufacturing. Right now, the US is
short 3.5 million manufacturing workers and the
worst part is that 2 million of these positions
are expected to go unfilled. This is definitely
not a good sign for supply chain issues easing
anytime soon. And given that 82% of manufacturing
executives feel that labor shortages are one of
the key reasons that they’re struggling
to meet demand and increase productivity,
this supply shortage could easily last for years
to come. It’s not just manufacturing workers that
are missing either, we’re seeing shortages
in the logistics side of things as well. The
American Trucking Associations estimates that
the driver shortage has increased from roughly
60,000 before the pandemic to 80,000 today. So,
not only has the pandemic reduced the number of
people who are producing goods but also the
number of people who are delivering goods.
INFLATION:
Aside from a major labor and scaling mess,
supply chains have also been challenged
by inflation. The price of raw materials
have skyrocketed throughout the pandemic, and
while they have cooled down from their peaks,
there’s still a ways to go. Take Aluminum for
example. Before the pandemic started, Aluminum
cost roughly $1700 per tonne. At the start of
the pandemic, prices briefly cooled down to $1500
before they exploded to nearly $4000 in February
of 2022. Since then, prices have come back down to
$2400, but that’s still 40% higher than where they
started. A similar story can be seen with Lumber.
Before the pandemic, Lumber generally costed $3
to $400 per 1000 board feet. From there, Lumber
crashed to $250 before rocketing to an eyewatering
$1600. Fortunately, we’ve cooled back down to a
little over $600, but that’s still over 60% higher
than where we started. This price volatility has
made everyone within the supply chain extremely
cautious because they don’t want their businesses
to become unprofitable. Here’s the thing,
let’s say you own the company that produces
chassis for iPhones. You already committed to
making X number of chassis at a given price,
but since you made this commitment, the price of
aluminum has doubled which leaves your business
unprofitable. At this point, you have two options.
You can either go to Apple and renegotiate a
higher price due to rising material costs which
will likely take weeks if not months. Or you can
wait for aluminum prices to cool down before you
ramp up production which will also take weeks if
not months. Meanwhile, if you’re about to form a
new manufacturing contract with let’s say Samsung,
you’re probably going to quote them a higher price
to protect yourself from price fluctuations. And
when Samsung hears this high price, they’re gonna
be inclined to get more quotes before their lock
in a manufacturing contract. And all of this just
slows down the process of meeting demand. Also,
keep in mind that most of these companies
aren’t just dealing with one supplier. Apple,
for example, has over 200 suppliers. So, Apple
would have to troubleshoot this same issue over
200 times at the same time. I don’t think I need
to explain how this quickly turns into a supply
chain nightmare. To make things worse, Apple’s
issues won’t be solved once they get all of their
suppliers on board. Now, they have to worry about
actually transporting the finished product to the
customer. Fortunately, gas prices aren’t that
bad, wait nevermind crude oil is floating at
over $100 per barrel. I don’t even think I need to
explain why this is a problem because most of you
have likely dealt with obscene gas prices first
hand. Now, companies could just go ahead and raise
prices like many of them have been doing, but with
recession fears being rampant, consumers are more
price sensitive than ever. Last quarter,
Netflix lost nearly a million subscribers,
so there’s no doubt that consumers are cutting
back on expenses. So, the last thing companies
want to do is raise prices too fast and lose even
more customers. As a result, many companies have
decided that its better to have customers wait as
they try to source cheaper materials than it is to
have customers leave because they raised priced.
This mindset is by no means helping the situation.
RUSSIA-UKRAINE WAR:
The pandemic along with
inflation were already massive challenges
to deal with, but now we also have to deal
with the Russia-Ukraine war. Neither Russia nor
Ukraine are massive manufacturing players per se,
but this isn’t to say that they don’t have a
significant impact on the global supply chain.
Ukraine was one of the world’s top sources
for neon. Now, neon might seem irrelevant,
but it’s actually extremely relevant when
you consider that neon plays a crucial role
in semiconductor manufacturing. You see, neon is
required to run the lasers that are used in the
chip making process. And given that 90% of the
neon that was used to produce US chips came from
Ukraine, this is not a great sign. Neon wasn’t the
only item that came from Ukraine either. The war
has also cut off significant supply of nickel,
aluminum, wheat, and sunflower oil. And all of
that is just Ukraine’s side of things. Russia is
third largest oil producer and second largest oil
exporter. Cutting of Russian oil is one of the
main reasons that gas prices have gone insane
over the past few months. And given that these
sanctions likely wont be easing anytime soon,
transportation networks are gonna have to get
used to higher fuel prices. Aside from oil,
Russia is also the world’s second largest natural
gas producer and the world’s largest natural gas
exporter. Given that the manufacturing industry
is heavily dependent on natural gas, they’re gonna
have to get used to higher natural gas prices
for quite some time. Aside from raw materials,
the war has also dispruted major transportation
networks. Here’s the thing, Russia is literally
the biggest country in the world by far, so when
you cut off all cargo trains, planes, and ships
from this region, it becomes a lot harder to
transport goods. In China, for example, over a
million containers became stuck in the logistics
channel when the war started. You see, these
containers were supposed to be transported to
Europe by a train that travels through Russia.
But, now all of them have to be transported
by sea. So, the Russia-Ukraine war is not only
taking a massive toll on raw materials but
also international transportation networks.
THE SUPPLY SHORTAGE:
In the end, I think Matthew Rozsa says it best.
The global supply chain is like a gigantic
spiderweb that was been created through decades
of producing, scaling, and delivering. And out
of nowhere, three giant baseballs have been
thrown at this spiderweb. The first baseball
is the pandemic. The lockdowns, layoffs,
and factory shutdowns brought on by Covid-19 have
been catastrophic. Scaling up production back to
full capacity is a time consuming endeavor and
this has been especially challenging due to labor
shortages. The second baseball is inflation.
The price increases in raw materials, labor,
and fuel have led to higher expenses in every
step of the supply chain. Meanwhile, companies
are trying to minimize price hikes to maximize
customer retention. And this has simply led to
companies putting supply chain issues on the back
burner instead of addressing them head on. And
finally, the third baseball is the Russian-Ukraine
war. Not only has the war cut off several key
resources such as neon, natural gas, and oil, but
it has blocked off almost all cargo transportation
through Russia. These three baseballs have
left three massive holes within the supply
chain spiderweb and this is not something that
can be fixed overnight. Given that many millions
of manufacturing jobs will remain vacant, the
clearest solution is to lean towards automation
which will take years to develop. Similarly, it
took a year for inflation to ramp up to where we
are right now. And even if this is the peak, it’ll
likely take another year for inflation to cool
back down. And as for the Russia situation, even
if the war ended today, it’ll take years if not
over a decade to repair relations. So, our best
bet is to simply find new sources of natural gas
and oil and neon, but this will again take time.
So, you should probably buckle in because this
crazy ride is far from being over, but that’s just
what I think. When you do you think supply chain
issues will ease? Comment that down below. Also,
drop a like if you hope supply chain issues ease
sooner rather than later. And of course, consider
checking out our discord community to suggest
future video ideas and consider subscribing
to see more questions logically answered.